hi there its senior reviews editor Peter
Brown standing in for reviewer Miguel
concepción to tell you about blood-borne
the old hunters the remaining humans and
blood-borne dead city of yharnam think
you're making a mistake to even consider
this new adventure when you talk to them
they say that there's nothing new here
for you that is a nightmare
they're incorrect on both counts as an
expansion that is a couple of areas and
one boss fights short of being truly
extensive the old hunter still has a
good deal of tests for hardened
blood-borne and souls enthusiasts and
know the reimagining of this gothic
urban landscape isn't a nightmare it's a
healthy field hunters like the main game
is replete with difficult encounters
especially against hunters and fearsome
bosses the enemies that lurk along
yharnam Start pathways are as ruthless
as any you would find in the main game
including father Gascoigne - the
creature transformation the new bosses
here greatly complement the large roster
from the main game and they're more
imaginatively designed and than what you
can find in the chalice dungeons to
these new bosses bring unexpected
tactics to the fight making it hard to
rely on your existing strategies a
couple foes such as the grossly deform
Ludwig fight back against tried and true
tactics such as rolling towards your
opponent so don't be surprised if they
bodyslam you when you least expected
despite this somewhat familiar world and
rules the old hunters isn't short on
surprises equally engrossing are the
mysteries born from the myriad riddles
hidden in conversations and cutscenes
the many new items included in the old
hunters add to the overall lore with
cryptic inscriptions - if you love the
back story there's value in reading the
history of an item as unassuming as the
constables trousers then there's the
beast hunter safe a predecessor of the
saw cleaver that suggests the events and
the old hunters preceded those in
blood-borne proper adding another
unexpected layer to Garmin's mysterious
past like many of the other weapons in
this expansion this safe space stats
don't deviate far from the arms and the
main game the same goes for the fists of
karate a crude hunk of iron that
effectively functions as a brass knuckle
in the ranges weapons slot while the
safe essentially functions like a stock
leaver you'll find nuance in the speed
of the combos with your hunter's arms
stretching a bit further with each swing
compared to the immediacy of the attack
from the sake alternatively you can now
wield a giant circular saw known as the
whirligig saw which attaches to an
almost equally lethal bent step aside
from being viable alternatives to the
flagship weapons it's intriguing to see
how these new tools work in action
[Music]
for as disturbing and depressing as
yharnam is in blood-borne it felt like
the dark city still had a chance at
redemption the version of this city in
the old hunters is beyond salvation all
the familiar paths are now covered in
what appears to be hardened dough with
fingerprint like lines and ridges
scrawled through them countless gallons
of blood drenched the lower areas
leaving you to wonder what in the world
happened since the last time you visited
the doom city the answer might be in the
broken sky above knowledge of the games
full maps and shortcuts are of no value
here so despite that you can recognize
many of the landmarks and yharnam none
of blood-borne 's previous locales feel
reused and instead offer new challenges
for devoted hunters the old hunters is
blood borne from another time in place
and with more difficult bosses and
confounding stories to unravel it's also
a great complement to the original
gruesome adventure
[Music]
you